The Marvel movies have come to be some of
the most successful films ever to be released.
Filled with likable characters, great stories
and jaw dropping effects, the Marvel films
are here to stay.
The films are often fairly funny, but some
of that humor doesn’t even make it into
the final cut.
Despite portraying some of the most popular
superheroes on the planet, even the actors
occasionally make a mistake and goof up on
set, resulting in a mistake worthy of laughs.
From Gods to aliens, scientists to mutants,
here are Screenrant’s 10 Marvel Bloopers
they couldn’t plan even if they tried.
If you got a kick out of this video, don’t
forget to give us a like, leave a comment
and subscribe to stay up to date on all things
screenrant.
Ant-Man
Remember in Captain America: Civil War when
Spider Man made that obscure reference to
that “old” movie called The Empire Strikes
Back before taking out Ant Man in a fashion
that was VERY reminiscent of the AT AT take
down?
Well turns out that wasn’t the first time
Ant Man found himself in a situation that
called out to a galaxy far, far away.
In a blooper from the 2015 film Ant Man, Paul
Rudd is filmed in costume mimicking none other
than C3P0 himself, copying the golden droid’s
stiff movements and voice before strutting
away, the crew behind the camera easily getting
a laugh out of the quick gag Rudd decided
to pull.
He also makes a quick reference to Taxi Driver’s
famous “you talkin’ to me” scene.
Rudd also later slips in some light swearing
with his young co-star, whom he believes to
be sleeping but she full on calls him out
on it shortly after.
Captain America: Winter Soldier
How many hits does it take to break a simple
lock with Captain America’s awesome shield?
As it turns out...many.
Chris Evans repeatedly brings shield to lock,
mocking a bashing movement only the dummy
lock won’t budge, resulting in Evans both
laughing manically and looking like a child
who just lost his candy, pouting in the corner.
Thankfully for Evans, he was able to muster
up some of that super soldier serum and eventually
break the lock, thank goodness.
A superhero isn’t much good if they can’t
break a simple lock.
The Avengers
Here we have a standout blooper that has become
something of an internet meme.
Despite being the God of Thunder and the proud
owner of Mjolnir, it looks like Thor still
isn’t quite so worthy to wield the mighty
hammer.
When the prop hammer is toss to Chris Hemsworth,
the actor miscalculates his catch and ends
up fumbling the hammer in a majestic juggle
in the mist of the alien invasion before ultimately
dropping it.
Now’s not the time for these shenanigans
Thor!
Guardians of the Galaxy
Guardians of the Galaxy was already a pretty
goofy movie, filled with hysterical moments
that have become a defining feature of the
space opera.
It should come as no surprise then that there
were a ton of equally funny blooper moments
that happened during the production of the
2014 hit.
One such moment was when Michael Rooker’s
Yondu decides to go full child mode on the
Broker, spewing pure jibberish over and over
again.
His fellow Ravager can be seen behind him,
trying very hard not to burst out into laughter.
Avengers: Age of Ultron
We all know the Avengers cast likes to have
on set.
Just check out Chris Evans and Scarlet Johansson
having fun with the classic “avengers assemble”
line from the end of Age of Ultron.
But what happens when the actors mess up in
such a way that is both completely unintentional,
amusing and the last thing you’d expect
to happen as an actor.
That’s what happened to Mark Ruffalo in
Ultron as the actor missed his footing completely
in the Avengers Tower set and slid down Tony
Stark’s elaborate penthouse catwalk, resulting
in an uncontrolled and rapid descent as he
flails his arms wildly.
Hopefully it didn’t make him mad.
Doctor Strange
How Strange.
When doing a fight scene without any actual
physical interactions, you’re bound to look
a little silly.
Benedict Cumberbatch took this to a whole
other level during the production of Doctor
Strange and took his choreographed moves beyond
the fight scene.
In the midst of battle, Cumberbatch decides
to turn his fight into a hilarious dance sequence,
complete with spins, shakes and sound effects.
To be honest, it’s not the strangest thing
we’ve seen in this movie.
X Men: Days of Future Past
Boy, she looked happy.
Days of Future Past brought back the original
cast of characters, including Patrick Stewart,
Hugh Jackman and Halle Berry.
During a scene with Berry, Jackman’s Wolverine
engages in some small talk with Storm before
full on making out with the surprised actress.
In typical Wolverine fashion, Jackman walks
away to a casual “see you later” but that
doesn’t stop Halle Berry from full on freaking
out in joy, jumping up and down screaming
yes.
I’m sure that’s how most women would react
to…heck probably the men too (be honest).
Avengers
Leave it to Mark Ruffalo to have fun on yet
another Avengers movie.
For a guy who plays an “angry green rage
monster”, he certainly knows how to let
loose on set.
In the film, Ruffalo’s Bruce Banner is about
to reveal to everyone that his secret is that
he’s always angry.
Yet that’s not what happened at some point
during the shoot.
When the sound effects for the Asgardian Whale
cue in, Banner straight up just bolts from
the action, leaving Captain America behind
with Hawkeye with an amused “dude you’re
on your own!” being hollered as he flees
the scene.
Chris Evans can’t help but crack a smile
before the camera pans to show Scarlet Johansson
starting blankly into oblivious before realizing
Ruffalo just passed her by.
Spider Man 3
Leave it to J.K. Simmons portrayal of J. Jonah
Jameson to make the cut for having a hysterical
blooper moment that unsurprisingly, fits in
completely with his character.
When confronting his boss about running a
particular headline, Ted Raimi’s Hoffman
finds himself grabbing a set of chimes to
protect himself from Jameson’s furious rage.
Unfortunately for Hoffman, the chimes fell
apart when he grabbed them, resulting in Jameson…or
J.K. Simmons to yell out “you broke my f******
chimes!” before turning to face the camera,
unable to fathom the incompetence of his peer.
Deadpool
Leave it to the Merc with the Mouth to have
the shock and awe bloopers.
To be honest, most of the gags and accidents
from any of the Deadpool gag reels could fall
into legitimate film footage since they fit
the tone of the film perfectly, from its crude
humor to the overuse of “colourful” language.
One such instance was when co-star TJ Miller
compared Gina Carano’s Angel Dust’s haircut
to, well, a not nice way of saying it looked
like Justin Beiber did some not so PG13 things
to Miley Cyrus’ haircut.
Why wasn’t this in the final film?
The crown jewel however is when Reynolds is
in the car during the opening action scene
and messes up his fight choreography, resulting
in Reynolds breaking into song, joining by
the smiling and head weaving stuntman and
a very confused driver, who has to look over
his shoulders to make sure he’s actually
hearing this right.
Perfect.
So there you have it folks, 10 marvel bloopers
they couldn’t plan even if they tried.
Do you agree with our list?
What is your favorite comic book blooper?
Whatever it is, comment below to let us know!
The fun doesn't stop here though screenrant
fans, hop on over to CBR for even more awesome
content and sign up for the notification squad
to stay up to date on all the awesome videos
coming your way!